[Music]
hello and welcome to the master Dennis
Bosch and this is grandmaster's choice
we're actually going to talk about the
reigning and current world champion ding
lyron from China so there is something
that we got to clear up before we get
into anything there are some news
circling around in the mass media but
truth be told China already has a world
champion XI Jun was the first Chinese
women's world champion but they did not
have the male world championship title
as of today and I mean as of April 30th
we've got dingleran as the male world
champion
and what is fascinating that he actually
went through a long journey including a
time of the pandemic
actually I want to talk a little bit
about so this lecture is going to
Showcase dengleren's style which is
somewhat mysterious and you could
actually see that in the reactions once
he won the World Championships uh he
wasn't as big of a favorite he's not as
well known even for the best of the best
players they are kind of mystified by
his talent
is a little bit a bit on the artist's
side so more in interested in the Arts
plus of course chess but that's nothing
unusual if you are a top Grandmaster
so what is fascinating is that through
the pandemics times he played the
candidates a very Infamous candidates
which actually got uh cut in two parts
where they had to play half of the event
the pandemic happened and then they had
to restart and another time now
interestingly enough and the first half
he had an atrocious event but the second
half he had a magnificent candidates
tournament but by that time he was so
much lagging behind mvl and apple nyachi
that he really never got a chance to
catch up
and um
has nobody really paid attention at
least for me it kind of caught my eye
that
um even though the tournament was sort
of basically over he really never got a
chance to recover and qualify to the
world championship match which would
have been the match that Napo played
against Carlson
um he's nevertheless mustered the energy
to actually play and uh play really
really well
so ding actually is very well known for
me at least for his fighting Spirit he's
not as specially dazzling as of recent
but he used to be a very very aggressive
Kings Indian player but that was before
he became a super Grand Master so that
sort of is shrouded in mystery now
before we get into it I wanted to you
have a couple of words about his love
for arts and poetry so he actually
mentioned in one of his recent
interviews that
um
when he was down and was struggling in
this world championship match he turned
to the Poetry of Albert Camus and read
the lines
well the lines of if nothing ever works
for me may as well try to fight as hard
to survive the storm and etc etc trying
to weather the storm and not actually
just get depressed just because of the
situation is being grim and not
necessarily what he wanted it to be but
enough of that let's get into some games
let's start with this game between
dingler and Alexander gristio now
grishek is a very well-known player
um he's been in the candidates just like
Peter swidler they've been in the
candidates have been there consistently
so C4
E5 G3 and well if you've seen the world
championship match it's no surprise ding
actually opened with E4 well E4 he
didn't do but he did go on it F3 D4 and
C4 so actually did play a lot of variety
C4 E5 G3
this one is actually trying to avoid
very popular lines and in general the
idea of Bishop B4 which is trying to
ruin the structure for white in fact
this has been very topical even in the
80s when karpov and Kasparov was
battling these positions the E4
oftentimes they would go Knight D4 or
sometimes Knight T1 and this was
actually a game between Kasparov and
carpool
so
avoiding all these ideas avoiding this
bishop B4 pin or semi-pin rather then
goes for G3
and F6 Bishop G2 Bishop C5 D3 now Bishop
C5 is a much more rare move it's
something I played early on and with
great success the whole idea is if you
ever go or want to go Knight F3 that
sort of runs into E4 and ig5 still runs
into tricks like Bishop F2
so why it actually has to make a couple
of Preparatory moves that otherwise
wouldn't necessarily be that useful
so goes D3 as I said so in case of let's
say castles he can go Knight F3
comfortably because in a case of E4 you
capture and then you Castle
and these are actually typical
um English positions where black may
have sound position but why does the one
controlling all the important squares
so what you'll notice in dinglorand's
play I mean sometimes he dazzles you
with tactical play overall but sometimes
he's just accumulating the smallest of
advantages and tries to go from there
this is that type of position
so D5 takes Knight C3 Knight B6 somewhat
unusual most people were going Knight F6
and this I believe was the original idea
of Alexander griestio but a couple of
words about Grisha so yes I talked about
the fact that he's been in the candidate
but he was also pretty close to winning
The Knockout World Championships so
we're used to the era where you play
matches for the world championship title
but there was a figure segment where you
had knockout World Championships and in
those knockout World Championships he
would go as far as the quarterfinals or
even the semi-finals not going past that
past that but he would face players such
as vishyanand who is one of those
Champions who had won all formats of
chess
so even though Vichy isn't heralded as
one of the greatest I believe that's a
big mistake because if you think about
it vishi was one of those few who won
The Knockout events he won the round
robin events and won the classic World
Championships so practically won
everything that had World Championships
in it compare that to others not many
actually walked the won The Knockout
events which actually is somewhat harder
and much more roulette-like than the
world championship matches because you
play one person over and over again and
either that person fits your style or it
doesn't
anyways
Grace shook really is known for Creative
play he really loves playing something
that's offbeat and something that is
sort of his own brainchild
here again he comes up with the creative
move of Knight B6
and F3 Knight C6 castles castles A3 and
atha
okay so this position is somewhat
different from the usual ones because
the bishop is not on E7 but on C5
so if you're kind of new to the way I
give my lectures I always give
opportunities either for questions I'm
always open for those but also for you
to try to guess the move or try to you
know probe the positions that these
really really strong ground Masters are
playing so this is one of those moments
where I do want to ask all of you
watching here live
and
watching through the internet What wave
would you play in this position
now a little bit of a guidance for your
journey is that you still have this Rook
ambishop locked in not doing too much so
trying to get them out might be an idea
so any ideas and thoughts about this
position or the way you'd play as white
so what actually makes uh so like a
little bit of an anecdote here while um
all of you are thinking of the position
I do know a very strong super Grand
Master
um he's in his twenties and a budding
player one of the ways he actually
became so strong that he tried to guess
all these top players moves
basically guessing the moves and that
way he kind of found an affinity of how
the top players and top guys play chess
and talking about ding what was actually
kind of heartwarming and fascinating
that excision the women's world champion
of China actually showed up to support
dingler and in the very last rounds
which is kind of a support that you
don't always see
um in these matches
so Bishop E3 is an interesting idea the
only downside of going Bishop to E3 is
that you are voluntarily ruining your
own structure now that Bishop E3 is
necessarily bad but why create a
weakness but you don't have to
Bishop D2
and what is your idea
you're just getting the pieces in okay
any thoughts
but you play as white
if not that's okay
yeah 94 makes a lot of sense you want to
chase the bishop and then go Bishop E3
it didn't happen but that's definitely a
typical idea in these type of positions
you go here
and oftentimes you even go Bishop C5 the
biggest issue in these positions as
black that oftentimes white goes Bishop
to C5 and if this of course this trade
is a big blunder by black
but in that case this is a big Advantage
for white this is like the strategical
plan when you're playing on the white
side of the English if your knight could
land on C5 that would be marvelous
so one of the ways of playing is of
course Knight E4 Bishop D2 is a move you
can't play but it feels a little too
timid
or at least for right now and the other
move that is actually kind of popular is
going Bishop G5 provoking some
weaknesses I mean if you go back you
lose time if you move your queen when
your queen is not ideal here and if you
move this Pawn then
this diagonal becomes really weak
now actually ding chooses a different
option and let's be very clear here ding
is probably out of his preparation while
Grace shook is obviously prepared
so any of the moves that seems very
logical Knight E4 Bishop G5
Etc or even Bishop D2 is very likely is
in grischuk's notes so when ding decides
to go Knight to A4 it also is trying to
throw off Grace choke and just meet him
on a fair ground so there's a little bit
of psychology going on and not
necessarily trying to find the best move
because they might just find themselves
one-on-one with an engine
because of a home preparation
so take sticks Knight D4 now Knight D4
even though not at all a bad move may
not be that great you could also just go
Rook to E8 over defend the E pawn move
the bishop away
because Knight D4 actually creates a
problem for black
can any of you guessed what could be
sort of the issue that this night move
what could be the problem with this
what could be the downside that's what
I'm trying to say
and it you you shouldn't really be
thinking that there's something
horribly wrong with it obviously it's a
legitimate move in the position
but it does sort of loosen
uh black script
but what way you guys think
how does it loosen the grip
the pawn is not defended and also this
bishop on G2 becomes much much stronger
when there's a couple of pieces in front
on C6 or D5 that Bishop is sort of
stifled by those pieces when you go on
id4 you're basically voluntarily opening
up this white squared Bishop which is
sort of the crown jewel of White's play
of course you can't quite take on E5
because there's Knight takes E2 check
so takes Bishop takes okay now this next
move what uh
actually ding plays is something I
really really like because it thinks
about not his own plan but about Black's
best pieces she's more interested in
just outdoing rescue with whether peace
placement than just being busy following
his own plan it's just going to sabotage
ratio as much as possible
so your goal should be to look around
and say hmm
does black have a good piece
how can I reduce the Damage Done by that
peace
well obviously those Rooks don't do too
much you're not too scared of those
we're mostly scared of this bishop on D4
right
it's sitting it's throwing it's on the
throne on D4 and it's in a Central
Square
so here he goes Bishop D2
but now he goes E3 as planned and the
whole idea is to kick out the bishop now
if you think here it would get trapped
because there's no way out if you go
here I just capture you and there's no
way back of course and even if you take
here I can take on B2 and I defend my
Bishop over there
so all is all white is doing is
restricting this bishop
Bishop B6 so
black was hoping to have all these
trades and say well my position is no
longer bad
and probably with every trade he
actually exposed more weaknesses the
weakness on A5 and the weakness on E5
so both of those pawns are actually a
little bit on the loose end
so it goes Bishop C3 and he actually
could try to take on D3 but Grisha can
sort of uh conservative and says well I
don't think I'm much worse why would I
take this Pawn but he definitely could
have taken the pawn and then the
position is more or less dynamically
equal
but he goes rookie E8 and that isn't
necessarily that great
okay so a next strategical problem we
have is deciding which Rook goes where
and that is what I want to see and
figure out
where should we put our rocks
so
oftentimes we look at games that are
which are very Tactical
and hopefully we'll have the time and
chance to do so
but this one is more of a strategic game
and here what really matters
is your peace positioning if you find
the right squares you may actually get a
chance to pressure your opponent you
misplace them you're going to be under
pressure
okay the one and where would the other
Roga
okay and what is the so you go here
here and what is this Rook going to do
it's gonna do what
which Pawn
okay
all right
so here here
okay is there any other formation we
could use
look at the age file there and moved the
so that it supports a
break later potentially okay
so two that's why you have two so two
muscle breaks so playing for All These
Bricks very good
so the issue with this one
in here
you sort of have to anticipate
of the consequences of your palm breaks
whenever you go rookie D1 Rook f e one
D4 and let's say you trade
well first off you will get kind of a
bad Pawn but if you don't like let's say
you go here you're just making a couple
of moves
if you think this way this Pawn is weak
you actually managed to get an open fifo
Rook
but at too much of a cost the pawn is
isolated
you take this way which would make much
more sense right because you keep it
intact and you got the formation still
but then what is this Rook on E1 doing
right
we don't quite know what it's doing
there
um so really you bring your Rooks where
they are going to be useful later on
so you'd rather bring this Rook
and go D4
because you sort of anticipate the
opening of the default right
so in that sense even keeping your Rook
here is better
so if the a file ever opens up your okay
is going to be useful
the only issue right now is anytime we
go Queen C2 because if we go B4 there's
always this capture and we can't really
capture back with the pawn which we wish
to
uh because of the Rook but anytime you'd
move the queen I can't push my Pawn
so I will basically stop you from Ever
playing B2 to B4
but anyways let's continue so Rook D1
Bishop D7 Rook C1
he's sort of realizing he's not going to
be able to go B4 because of all these
ideas from back
so Rook C1
H6
okay so we managed to find good spots
for our Rooks
but the question is if there's anything
left that we could sort of strengthen in
our position before we go for a break
now also be careful D4 still isn't that
great because of some tricks
so we don't want to fall for that just
yet
or at all
to be honest
okay the queen could get a better
position
so what would you consider where would
you post it
could
okay so the best way of thinking of
chess
is
you sort of look at a group of ideas or
candidates moves if that's familiar
um you could think of Queen C2 but I
wouldn't really stop here I'd say okay
that's one way of improving the position
but is there any other different ways of
improving which is not necessarily a
clean move
so sometimes you can actually
copycat your opponent
they are actually giving away ideas
every move I mean as long as you reach a
high enough level they have a purpose
so black actually purposefully pushed
this Pawn I'm gonna do the same right
and the whole point would be in that
case is that no background ideas anymore
and also I'm sort of restricting your
Bishop
now the question becomes are you going
to go here or are you going to move the
queen here or maybe you're thinking of a
third option
because it's also about comparing these
two you know just like buying an apple
you check them you check them which
one's better quality
same thing here
which one contains a bit more risk
yeah and if here then they can go A4
right
that is one of the issues
it goes H3
um and these are the sort of moves that
just go completely unnoticed for someone
who's unaware of how strategic chess
works
they're building they're slowly moving
forward but then you have to build it up
well so it actually work well enough
[Music]
um
H3 and this doesn't look so sparkling
and this is something that is a bit
petrossian like
um
the reason I'm mentioning iron tigrant
over here is because he loved to play
chess like this incremental chess where
you're building your position and you're
not necessarily giving away the
direction of your play
Rook B8 and Rook B8 I do not like and
rugby kind of shows that gristook has no
idea what he's going to do
he doesn't want to move the bishop
because he thinks that the bishop is
better here doesn't want to move this
bishop because it has some tricks on the
queen doesn't want to move anything else
because then these like then these guys
are a little bit loose
so there are some times when your
opponent has the move but they'd wish
they could just pass
if they move the king then the pawn
becomes weak
so even though white is by no means
winning or anything like that it's black
who's sort of struggling for choice
and Rook B8 doesn't really strike me
like a great move
for the reason it only defends the pawn
but I mean you do move away from the a
pawn
okay so do we still remember our
original goal is white chat and everyone
here live watching
what was our original plan
in this position
yeah breaking with D4
so we still kind of run into the idea of
this and that is kind of sad
but how can we prepare this idea
well
let me you do do make a good point that
the B4 break is better than it was
before
but that wasn't really our original plan
right we wanted the D4 break
and that's actually pretty important
once you decide and embark on one plan
try to stick with it because it actually
helps you improve your chess because if
you bounce around too much you don't
necessarily know what you're aiming for
so for that reason it goes Rook D2
he's actually going to prepare D4 you
could also argue Quincy as we talked
about
um but he feels no need to move this by
the way white would be super happy to
see C5 because then this bishop becomes
a Monster again
it doesn't necessarily mean this is
terrible of a move but it does give some
good strategical chances for white
krishu goes Bishop C7
and now he goes D4
notice that uh these strategic waiting
moves sort of uh unbalanced gristook
they don't seem that earth-shattering
yet they're pretty strong here D4
take C5 Queen C2 take Stakes C4
now a lot of things have changed now
green shoot doesn't take here because
right can take here and white has
immense amount of pressure on Black's
position for free so Grace Q goes for C4
silver is a very interesting idea and an
ambitious one but ding sort of notices
what grishek wants
what do you guys think what is gratitude
planning to do
before and possibly
but
yeah they want a rule with b5b4
actually so not really A4 they're trying
to play for their majority
so they go for B5
that's the idea
and once you realize what the opponent
wants of course you want to do the
opposite or at least sabotage it
yeah then goes A4
if you push the beep on that doesn't
really stop anything black can still go
B5 and that actually gives black a
decent position
A4 is very nice
because if you go B5 I'm capturing and
your structure is in shambles
I can just push the pawn and it's just
the quality of pieces I've got a
magnificent Bishop in fact Bishops and
your Bishops are subpar that Bishop on
B5 is just staring at the pawn on C4 and
these pieces aren't that much good
so it goes Bishop D6 instead
now
then realizing that his position has
changed a bunch
now he has a D4 upon
this Rook on D2 doesn't really do too
much
she goes Rook dd1
and that is somewhat of a shocking move
why would you go Rook D2 put pressure on
the D file then just go back and just
turn around well ding just decides the
situation has changed I need to control
the file
I already have an extra
Pawn here that I can use later on in the
game
so B6 over key one Rook takes Rook takes
Queen C7
upon H4 gaining a little bit of space
now
and this is not really readily known
information about Chess but of course
you want to get control in the middle
but if you could also expand on the
sides that's how you slowly uh win the
game H4 is also trying to cram down
black
rookie eight
Bishop D5
not just attacking this Pawn but
centralizing the bishop and also winking
at that pawn on F7
takes Bishop takes Bishop E6
and this is actually the critical moment
for ding
whether to capture or if we do how are
we going to follow up
if you just look at this position
briefly you have this feeling and
there's not much happening however
Christian's position is slowly uh
actually falling to pieces
okay so what is black going to do after
Queen E4
okay and then what are you planning to
do after
so we're talking about Queen to E4 takes
Queen takes
it is a good Square
but what are we going to do once we got
the square
I probably will move my king
here
probably move my Bishop you check I move
welcome Gogo
so as I said before
trying to create more targets we're
trying to create more problems for
griststroke
in this position
at least ding is trying to
taking the bishop
so leave that point
and by the way you can mix ideas so I'm
not necessarily saying what makes shares
difficult
when I said Queen E4 might not be the
most precise
it doesn't make the move bad it means it
may not work here
but sometimes it's sort of a combination
of the two
or two different ideas and you connect
them
and then Queen A4 yes
so that's sort of whole point if we go
here it takes
they stand pretty
but we don't actually have like a clear
way of winning or finding a way to break
through
because black has Richard built kind of
a very very solid position I mean he's a
great player
so we actually have to create more
Targets in his camp so taking here is
very important because now there's two
Pawn weaknesses and the king is awfully
um
Breezy over there so Queen E4
King F7
white goes Bishop to C3 and I really
like the way ding plays there's just a
lot of aim for harmony
Bishop C3 isn't the most staggering move
but if we come back
in this position the queen and the
bishop aren't really doing that much we
are putting pressure on C4 but they're
sort of lingering on the board and in a
couple of moves
both of these pieces are improved to the
max
so a position which didn't seem as um
promising is almost near decisive and in
fact restock is collapsing soon D5
an issue is not only am I pressuring on
the long diag you still have plenty of
weaknesses including your king and the
pawn on C4
screen D6 takes
check
King G8
Bishop D4
small move but the whole point is to
over defend the F2 square and hit the B6
spawn and also taken away any sort of
tricks
I mean F5
King H2 look that he's still not
hurrying at all
he just made sure that the bishop can't
move away that would be a problem by the
way because
um
if that Bishop could be traded off the
queen endings are usually drawn
regardless if you're up a pawn or not
and by the way of course you can never
go here because all of your pawns would
just fall and this is what I was saying
millia moves ago those spawns were
defended but not their weaknesses
because there's nobody left to defend
them
King H2
I mean C2 check Queen F7 again just
keeping the control completely and now
black is just near Lost Queen D3 Bishop
C3 and E6 unfortunately for black you
can't defend both the bishop I mean if
you move it it's made
and you can't defend the C pawn and the
f8 bishop the same time so it's just
collapsing
in D6
if we take C4
Queen G6 Bishop D4 and here Grace shook
just resigned because all is he going to
see is white going Queen C3 Queen E3
pick up all those pawns and it's game
over
so one of our first impressions of this
game of dingley RAM
how would you describe this
stylistically
very subtle right
there are a couple of tactics but not
not really the core right it's it
happens sometimes but it's very
strategic
slow-moving petrocyanesque
and I mean here I refer obviously to
iron tegran uh tigranvartanovic The
Armenian world champion
so just this slow subtle grinding play
not um
and Grisha seemingly barely made any
mistakes right not not like oh a blunder
here or a pawn falling there
it was just that he got squeezed off the
board
mostly I would actually fault the fact
that he started Trading
because it made it easier for white to
come closer to those weaknesses on E5
and A5
I believe that was sort of the culprit
why
um Rich Exposition fell
but talking about
a game that is amazing
is the game between Beijing she and
dingleran
and this game
was unbeknownst to me is actually
ding's favorite
so
even though you've seen a classical
strategic brilliancy in a previous game
you're going to see what was the young
and upcoming dingler end
it's D4
C4 this is a classical nimso Indian very
popular
castles so here there's plenty of moves
there's Pawn C5 there's Pawn D5 which
would actually transpose to the ragozan
but dingler and chooses castles
Bishop G5
C5 E3 C takes and queen takes D4 now you
may not be familiar with all the details
of this position
you may still notice that this queen
takes D4 move might be somewhat
suspicious right
we think about it what makes this move
somewhat subpar
it helps you develop the night with
Tempo but what actually is going to come
to light wow we figure out this game
is that this not just loses time for the
queen
it actually
does not help why it's development
white actually does not spend enough
time to put his King into safety
like the main line is Pawn captures and
eventually white will Castle
but here
ain't gonna let that slide here H6 very
very cunning little move winning time on
the bishop and also creating a lift for
the king so in general I am always on
the side of playing this move because
it's such a multi-purpose one
with plenty of ideas
so Bishop H4 and the next move here by
ding Loren is very logical
um yet still very strong
D5 your opponent's king is in the middle
you should strike in the center
so dingler and even though
um
very very aggressive in this game he
still uses the basic principles of chess
Rook D1 okay so now here comes the big
question how can we inch closer to this
King
and we may actually have to use some
drastic measures
now you may notice that we kind of
pinned all around the board
right
pinned all around
now
we need to untangle first to be able to
be aggressive
in this case
Queen A5 makes sense however our
position is probably going to collapse
after a capture and pawn capture
it's not gonna work out in our favor
yep G5 indeed
so a very very risky move
you are weakening your structure but
then I think does play apart from being
someone who's very good at calculating
he does understand
the strategy of this game quite deeply
like okay yes I actually make my king
vulnerable but your king is going to get
exposed
and as it said correctly in chat that
will allow him to pop the Knight to E4
Knight D2
well here Knight capture isn't really
that good
because what can always go back with the
bishop and on pin and why it doesn't
really have enough material and pieces
around the king to checkmate
foreign
so here Knight E4 Knight D2
so do we trade
or do we avoid that idea of trading
of course we don't trade
because when you're on the attack
anytime you trade you make life easier
for your opponent you don't want that if
they manage to cancel you are going to
be in big big trouble
because the king is going to be
extremely weak and if anyone's going to
play for a win it's not going to be
black
so goes Knight C5 Queen C2
D4 opening it all up of course you can
take care zygon id4 and I'm actually
opening it all up for me so Beijing she
goes Knight F3
banking on the fact that our Queen is
pinned
so the next sequence of moves by ding is
quite astonishing
but very logical and I think that's
something that you can't uh
forget
anytime he's going for something very
sharp he still follows the principles
so if you're talking about principles is
there still some pieces for black that
are not participating
what
which piece is not participating
mm-hmm
and therefore E5 right
so see how it is easy it is you realize
some of your pieces don't do too much
nothing is as logical as going E5 right
now so this bishop can be involved in
the game
Knight takes E5 and here comes
the shocker
bam D takes C3
gives up the queen
says I'm gonna get only light pieces and
a rook but that's gonna be enough
because your king is in the middle and
I'm not really scared of that Stakes CB
2 Rook D2 probably was better but
it's it's still very sound but King E2
is reasonable he believes that nothing
wrong can happen here
Rook takes d8
Queen takes B2 now this is the moment
we've got to be very very very
aggressive
because if we're not we're just lost
yeah we're just too
too many materials down we just to be
much behind here
so our goal will be
to launch our attack we'll be to launch
the attack here
in case of Bishop F5
I will capture this Knight
you can check me but I will try to run
away
Bishop F5 I take and I take your Bishop
and you run out of pieces very quickly
so we kind of realize in these positions
that time is of essence right
meaning
mostly you like to play moves
that either check the opponent
or attack something very valuable so
they don't really have time to react
or play something of worth
that would help the bishop on F1 and The
Rook on H1
yes just go on here
and what's our destination
yeah you want to go to C3 yeah
now Rook D2 wouldn't really work because
they just capture everything we run out
of pieces and the attack dies down
so here check here
and now here comes
dings most spectacular move
this move
is probably
among the recent brilliances of our
chest now of course he isn't as beloved
as many other players but this one
definitely deserves the highest of the
High Praise
and it just shows how creative Dean can
get if he's given the opportunity
H5 you are sort of hitting at the right
idea
H5 probably I'm gonna go H3
G4 G4 I do capture
F5
okay
so
your move has to have a goal
and it's not necessarily a bad thing if
you're threatening checkmate
boom
Rook D4
Quine An Elegant move
you can't touch this because
Fork
and you definitely can't touch this
because this is made
so black
forcing white to go H3 but now
we continue on we go in a tribe
if you go there well that's still mate
quite beautiful
Bishop H2
G4
King G3
so let's see
how can we chase this King around still
94.
and actually he doesn't even go there he
goes Rook D2 first
so he notices this idea but he's again
uh using the fact that in this case I
have Knight E4 and you just lose the
queen
me three now he goes Knight E4
check takes
and you know whenever you're playing a
brilliancy
you know that you're creating something
for
eternity so your heart is bumping you're
like oh my goodness this is going to be
epic
but look at ding's next move
King G7
cool calm and collected all he wants
to get the Rook over
that's all he wants nothing else and
it's made actually if it yes there it's
me
so Bishop F4
Bishop F5
just just chilling you go here
go here Netflix of course this is just
made
not much you can do about it
so go screen takes B7
Rook takes F2
and again just setting up this simple
made in one so it takes mate
you got all of your pieces still in the
garage and there's not one she can do
there
Bishop G5
Rook h8
setting up this idea you take
mate
so takes on F7
Bishop G6
takes on G4
and this next move by ding is basically
the coupler grass
which
is a beautiful move and just wins in
style
this is probably the nicest ending move
it's not mate yet but this next move is
the beginning of the end
I'd like to move and win
now of course you gotta roll with the
attack otherwise you are definitely
behind
Bishop F5 I move my king
I will block it with my Bishop
but just a disclaimer this move is
equally as spectacular as was the
previous
five six moves
we'll capture this Knight well
that's a fine move but it doesn't really
threaten Checkmate this next move is
threatening
is actually fourth checkmate
the sequence of force moves and it's
made
check
resides why because if you think here
here check here mate
so
what makes this game fantastic
is how ding used all the Strategic
principles just to finish up the game
with a furry flurry of attack
and they couldn't really stop it at all
because it was strategically sound at
the same time
so I really hope all of you enjoyed
these games I hope you kind of saw that
ding's game is actually very Universal
even though he prefers to play Slow
strategic chess he is very much capable
since childhood to play masterpieces
such as this one so thank you so much
for coming and thank you for listening
[Music]
thank you
foreign